Time
Time is a funny thing
it all gets mixed up
The past
the future
There's only one way
Always remember who you are
to keep it straight
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my Avatar,
The Last Airbender Netflix trailer breakdown.
There's a bunch of Easter Eggs here, obviously
a lot of very familiar things from season
one or book one.
They haven't said
exactly how much of book one
they're going to adapt for season one,
but it sounds like they're going to try
and do everything
but one of the main differences with Avatar,
The Last Airbender, is that there's way
less original material from that original series
than there was for one piece.
so I think one of the big differences is
they're actually going to be adding a bunch of scenes
that were not in the original series.
The things that were only alluded to or references
or flashbacks that they'll just expand on.
Like you probably noticed in this trailer video,
that there were a couple of scenes
that were not in the original book one episodes.
of course I'll be doing videos for everything
when it premieres in February 22nd next year, 2024.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
If you're brand new to the channel
some of you may have been subscribed to my channel
since I did videos for the original Korra series,
like that's how long it's been Mike
and Brian are also separately working on New Avatar,
The Last Airbender, animated movies and animated series
with like the next Avatar, like the Earth
bending Avatar after Korra, that stuff won't start
premiering until 2025 though, so it'll be a while
before we actually see any footage from that stuff.
But the whole idea with the next Avatar,
The Last Airbender animated movie is that it's
going to take place after the events of book three
with the adult version of Team Avatar.
So it'll be a lot of stuff that you saw in the comics
probably, but I think everybody's way more optimistic
about what this live action Netflix series
is going to be like because of the successes
of one piece Season one like it turned out
way better than I think people could have hoped for.
way more hype going into this now
after seeing one season one
but you starting at the beginning of the footage here
it starts with Sozin's comet,
which is probably a flashback at the beginning
to explain
how the 100 year war with the Fire Nation started
because the temple it passes over
Because the temple that it passes over
is meant to be the Southern Air temple where it grew up
before he took out, basically got afraid, took off,
and wound up getting stuck in the ice.
Then they basically show the fire Nation
attacking like all of its Aerostar firing.
As you hear Monk Gyatso speaking, ING's former
Airbending master talking about the influence of time,
like the past, the future mostly to highlight him
getting stuck in the ice
for 100 years, then coming out and things
being a little bit different.
a lot of these events are covered
at the very beginning of book one.
Like there are a couple different flashbacks
and they break things up a little bit, but you kind of
get a lot of that story
at the very beginning of episode one.
We'll see if they open the series doing the exact
same thing that they did during the animated series.
basically like a giant tutorial on the world
in what happened to start
the Hundred Years War and how things wound up
the way they are when the series begins.
whole idea though, the reason why Fire Lords SOS
and try to eradicate the airbenders
like why he's trying to basically commit genocide
on all the Airbenders here is
because they knew the next avatar after Roku
was going to be an Airbender,
so he wanted to try and eliminate the next Avatar
before he could rise,
thinking that he would eliminate all avatars
like completely Eradicate the avatar.
Reincarnation cycle.
so even though at the time he didn't know who Aang was
specifically, he was just trying to kill all Airbenders
so that there could be no airbender avatar to rise
had he been successful, obviously wish he was not,
the avatar cycle would have just continued in a water
bending avatar would have been born.
wave ashes.
Then Korra like the whole idea is the avatar
cycle is the way they regenerate.
Eng was the Airbending avatar,
the next avatar was Korra who came from the water
bending tribe and then the next avatar after her,
which they'll do on this Mike and Brian animated
Avatar series will be an Earth bending avatar.
there are a couple of scenes
where you see him going to the Crescent Islands,
which is basically the events of the winter solstice,
where he actually meets Roku.
And Roku starts to explain to him what he needs to do,
like learning
all the different elements
before the arrival of Sozin's Comet comes back.
the couple moments where you start to get Roku's back
story, too, and you learn how the 100 year war
wound up of
like the whole concept of Sozin's Comet, White fire
and all those
and even started the war in the first place.
basically the idea is that Sozin used to be roku's
best friend that they grew up together.
But once he became the fire Lord,
he learned about the existence of the comet
and it would give them basically God to your power,
like all fire benders would become way
more powerful learn potentially
he could conquer the entire planet using that power.
So kind of twisted him dark.
And that's why he started the war to begin with.
Roku tried to stop him, basically wound up sacrificing
himself in the actor, trying to calm things down.
right after that ng was born
and Sozin makes a beeline for the airbenders
to try and eradicate them, to eliminate the possibility
that an airbending avatar could rise.
R.I.P. Airbenders.
When Johnson's voiceover mentions the future,
it shows the events of episode one.
Basically, boy in the ice with guitar and Sokka
seeing him in the ice with Appa
and you can actually hear the ice cracking.
So it's like the act of him coming out of the ice.
The interesting thing about this, too,
is that there is no actual water
bending that happens anywhere in the trailer.
obviously not a lot of earth bending either,
because I think they're saving a lot of that
for season two when Toph winds up showing up.
but after they show Katara watching
and come out of the ice,
you actually see the gates of mansion in the Earth
Kingdom opening as he gets
ready to reunite with King Bumi, his old friend,
who is an old man now inn.
I know everybody has been wondering about Cabbage man.
There is like a really quick blink and you'll miss it.
Cabbage Man teaser.
So we know these in the series because he shows up
during this episode for the first time, zoom in
and hands when you see the gates of a martian opening,
he's like, right there, right at the opening.
as they pan out the city up to the palace, you see
the giant slides that run through the entire city.
they haven't said how many episodes
are going to be in season one.
But I'm assuming it's going to be eight.
They'll be about an hour long.
So they'll basically adopt about 2 to 3 episodes
per a single episode of the Netflix series.
then we see a bunch of scenes of what looked like stuff
that was not in the original series.
This is Zuko in his military uniform
at the Fire Nation Palace.
It seems like probably a scene when he departs
to leave on his journey to find the avatar.
Basically when he was exiled by his father,
a firelord Ozai.
You can see Uncle Ira watching him seems kind of sad,
like his plight when they're leaving the fire nation.
That's why he's so melancholy.
The idea is that Ira wasn't banished either,
but he chose to join Zuko in his exile
to watch over him
Because Zuko is kind of like a surrogate son to him.
And even though he hasn't admitted to it
at the beginning of the series here,
Zuko kind of thinks of Ira as his real father to
they're a bunch of Zuko flashbacks
that they showed later in the trailer, too.
I'll get to in a second.
Then we see what looks like a giant bird.
For a second, I thought this might be the giant
al washy tonk, but it might just be a messenger Hawk.
the point is that washy tongue in the library
don't really show up till like book two
since like a whole season two kind of thing,
which is why I don't think that this is the case
most of the footage we see here
doesn't cover up to the finale of book one.
I think they're leaving that off
just because the teaser is meant
to show you the beginning of the series,
like maybe up till like halfway
also the surrounding area around here.
Like, this is all night.
So it's kind of hard to see what's going on
because it's so dark.
but this doesn't really look like the library
even in its currency, even if it were a flashback.
So I think the idea is this might be a messenger hawk
and it actually might be
from the Blue Spirit episode
because they did use a messenger hawk during that.
That's basically when Zuko donned the Blue Spirit
mask to save ink from Zhao's Fire Nation prison.
so the Zhao wouldn't be able to take the avatar to fire
Lord Ozai and claim
the honor of finding
and being the one to find him before Zuko could.
because that Zuko's whole idea
at the beginning of the series, he's
trying to find the avatar to reclaim his honor
so that he can return home.
So essentially he has to save NG
so that he can be the one to turn him in.
Generally.
Even though Zuko kind of begins
the season as an antagonist
and the real villain of season
one is actually Commander Yao.
Then we actually see Daniel Dae Kim as fire
Lord Ozai in the Fire Nation Palace.
That's where the fires are behind him here.
Then we see Suki for the first time with Sokka
and the Kyoshi Warriors of Kyoshi Island.
I believe we'll see flashbacks with Avatar
Kyoshi during the series as part of this.
Do I think they actually did cast a live action?
Kyoshi the island that NG is flying to.
Here, though is the Crescent Island Fire Temple
and it's during the events of Winter Solstice.
Part two when Aang travels to the Fire temple
to hear the message from Avatar Roku
about what he has to do in order to stop Lord Ozai
from conquering the rest of the planet is basically
putting a ticking clock on the entire series,
which is the culmination in Book three.
he wakes up learning about his past lives, the avatars
before him, and about Sozin's comet in general.
It's basically a giant tutorial for Sozin's Comet,
Roku telling him he has to learn to master all
four elements by the time Sozin's comet arrives again
or that's it lights out for the rest of the world
At this point in the series, though,
he has not learned to water Ben yet.
They're still going to the northern water tribe.
that's the events of the season finale.
Maybe that'll be the season one Netflix finale here
or they push it to season two.
It would be weird
if they push it to season two, though.
then we actually see NG doing some genuine Airbending
They use the classic Avatar, The Last Airbender
theme music sort of kicks in.
this scene is actually meant
to be from Zuko's back story.
This is him facing fire.
Lord Ozai.
His father is from the scene
where he basically gave him his scar.
The whole idea is that he wound up accidentally
dishonoring the generals in a war council meeting.
so Ozai makes him face him in combat,
but he refuses to attack his father.
So basically his father gave him his scar in that's
how he wound up being sent into exile
with the idea that if he were able to find the avatar
and bring him back, It would restore his honor.
But it was a task that his father never really assumed
that he would be able to complete.
Like he didn't expect Zuko to actually find the avatar.
we see scenes of Zuko and present day on a ship,
putting up drawings
of the avatar maps all around the world
as he continues to search for him.
now, here's the idea.
Notice that the picture does not look like actual Aang.
It just looks like a generic Airbender.
that's because Zuko doesn't
actually know what Aang looks like.
He only knows that the avatar is an Airbender,
which is why the face looks a little bit older too.
He doesn't know the of the child.
there's a scene of Zuko and Ira fighting together.
This might be against Zhao's people
because like I said, there's this whole rivalry
between Zuko and Zhao during the season
Then we see a bunch of scenes of azula, probably scenes
that were not in the original series.
I think they expanded on her role
in the Netflix season one
because she wasn't really in book one
that much like she shows up very briefly at the end.
It is a much bigger character during season 2.
It'll be fun to see her
go full blown crazy town during the series.
There's a brand new scene of guitar.
And Sagar not really sure where they are
here in this scene just because it's so dark.
this is a scene of Aang entering the Avatar state.
This might be from when he returns to the Southern Air
temple and finds everyone dead
and sort of realizes
what happened when he went into the ice.
this looks like the middle of Commander
Zhao attacking a village.
It might be Sokka,
it could be Zuko in Iroh getting ready to face an
But the big blast of air blowing everyone
back is from Aang using his airbending on all of them
then then taking off on Appa, escaping Zhao's men.
they're couple of big scenes of Momo highlighting
what he's actually going to look like.
He looks pretty decent.
This might be how they do Chopper during one
peak season two because we know they're going
be doing the chopper character.
it looks like they're going to Kyoshi Island
because Momo is still pretty new to them,
like he seems new to them in the scene in the events
of Kyoshi Island happened right after they met Momo.
Basically zooming in.
Han's also on the island here.
This seems like the statue of Avatar Kyoshi
There's a whole bunch of stuff that they tease
in this trailer here.
So there's anything you spotted
that I didn't talk about in the video?
Just write it below in the comments.
And because the series is coming in February,
we'll probably get a bunch more trailers
before the end of the year.
really, really happy.
We don't have to wait that long
before we actually get episodes,
we'll probably get a bunch more bending
in the next trailer too.
like I said, generally optimistic about things
now just after the one piece season one on Netflix.
So we'll see like fingers crossed there are a bunch of
other things they've already released for the series.
So click here for my other trailer video and click here
for all my other Avatar The Last Airbender videos.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!